I was getting out to get coffee and
there was a note ozone this was today
there was no Thoth there's like a
towaway zone it was like a towaway zone
was like you can't park here so I parked
there because if there's a parking space
I'm gonna [ __ ] sit do it dude
it's so annoying one thing places are
like don't park and you're like why I
get it if there's like a whole [ __ ]
thing and it's like ah because then the
people can't get out the thing I don't
to block anybody dude there's no [ __ ]
reason for the tollway [ __ ] so I parked
there cuz I'm a person and I'm in a car
and I need to [ __ ] get out so I
parked there and then I got into the I
got out of my car and by the way four
cars could could fit and this guy parks
in front of me and he says moment is
Ella or whatever the [ __ ] I don't listen
to people when they say something for
the first time because who are you and
why you know just a random person also
I'm not ready get out the car with the
with the girl and this guy goes oh mom's
uploading some dumb and I say oh yeah
and I look at her and I don't know what
the [ __ ] he says and he says and he and
then he says or not and I was like oh
this [ __ ] getting
passive-aggressive on me dude how do you
know what the [ __ ] he said and he's
getting some or not or not dude you know
what or not is for texting only only and
even still you should just write lol hey
want to go to the baseball game no text
back next day lol or K you don't write
or not like you're a [ __ ] you note I
mean that's so [ __ ] but I'm would maybe
do or not on text but in person dude to
look at somebody and be like this or not
what are you doing chill dude
so he [ __ ] goes or not and I look
over and of course he's shorter than me
nobody who is taller than somebody ever
says or not to the person that's just
not how it goes
you are saying or not to somebody
congratulations you're shorter than them
there's no [ __ ] way if I'm six to the
guy who is saying or not to me is six
three there's no [ __ ] way so I look
over he's five five nine obviously okay
and I say oh man sorry I didn't hear you
and he says okay and I realized he was
saying I rewound it you know how you can
do that sometimes you could do the what
sometimes you like what and you didn't
hear it but sometimes you're like what
and you were like wait a minute
don't repeat yourself I could rewind
time in my head and hear the [ __ ]
so I rewound it you can go back like
[ __ ] nine seconds maybe at the most
maybe I'm a [ __ ] mutant maybe that's
my power I don't know but I rewound it
and I realized I went I went over the
[ __ ] sound scan that he did and I'm a
little bit and I rewound it and okay and
I turned it into what he said which was
oh you should have something you should
have a serozha oh you should have you
you could have moved back and or you
could have moved up and we both could
have parked there and I was like this
guy and I'm in the coffee place and I'm
looking at him and he's just in the
coffee place like this with his phone
cuz he's picking up for uber eats
he's just literally in the coffee place
like this holding his [ __ ] phone out
like this like he's like he's looking
like like it's that [ __ ] new thing
uber or lyft does where they make your
phone screen pink so you could tell when
[ __ ] Oh George is trying to pick you
up
by the way in LA if you [ __ ] get an
uber guy his name's Oh George I don't
give a [ __ ] what you who you think is
that I've never gotten an uber where the
guys name is an old York so like hey how
can I get a Pete can I get a hey Chris
hey it's Kris are you you Chris yeah you
Oh George of course we all are all
Jacques so it's over isn't it yeah get
in okay cool
get abducted by some other old York so
now I was the wrong old George I'm going
to take you in a hut and rape you so
then so anyway so I get to the what the
[ __ ] was I talk about yeah so then I get
out to look at this park job I did right
cuz of course I get out after he leaves
cuz he's in a [ __ ] hurry you know
so I get out after and I look and by the
way dude [ __ ] no [ __ ] where I
parked not even if I had parked the way
he said for other cars could have fit no
[ __ ] not an exaggeration for other
cars could have picked and I said what
the [ __ ] is the deal what this guy just
wants a complain bro